what is there in these lockdown files
that will convince those people who
don't agree with the three of us that
they should perhaps nothing because I
think there's something wrong with them
well good to hear you good to know you
came here
I mean look if you can't swayed it by
the content of these lockdown files that
this was just so profoundly wrong what
is going to persuade you what more does
it take you know we've got tens of
thousands of children who never went
back to school we've got a broken NHS
we've got an economy in Smithereens what
more evidence do you need do you really
still think it was a good idea to shut
Society down for that long when we had a
vaccine and when the mortality rates for
this condition were not particularly
high for anybody who wasn't already
above the age of life expectancy